[Music]
a lot of people heading to grab their
tickets ahead of tonight's drawing and
they're crossing a state line to do it
they're going a long way but it's
definitely worth it las vegas now jc
fernandez made the trip all the way down
to arizona's last stop for us hey jc
how's it going out there
hey christian it's great we're down here
in white hills arizona and it's easy to
get to just take the 11th south i live
in summerlin i got down here less than
an hour in order to win 1.2 billion
dollars you have to buy a lottery ticket
bill get over here bill's one of the
many here in line who's hoping to win
the billion dollars tonight you win it
what do you do with the money travel
around you and your wife and family do
some traveling that's it so i was
talking to bill before we came here and
it's hard to comprehend 1.2 billion
dollars they ask you at first you're
like i don't know what i'm gonna do you
start to think about it travel take care
of family maybe buy a car yep that's
pretty much it now are you picking your
numbers are you letting the machine pick
it a little both is there is there a
method to the madness someone's your
anniversary date
kids birthdays anniversary stuff like
that but the fact that you're on channel
8 right now it's a good luck charm so
good luck to you bill all right win that
billion dollars let's go talk to rachel
she's running this whole thing rachel
your staff is doing a fantastic job
everybody here is having a great time it
could be the winner tonight but let's
talk about a non-lottery friday what's
it like down here it is it's busy but it
is not this busy this is very very crazy
and do you recommend because bill over
there is picking some numbers what do
you think is better to to pick numbers
based on your your anniversary date or
your birthday or let the machine pick
the numbers you know i think it should
be split half and half you know put some
of your numbers in there and then let
the machine do it too
okay someone's watching in las vegas
right now it takes maybe 30 45 minutes
to get down here at what time do you
stop selling tickets tonight we stop
selling tickets at 6 55 that's when the
machine won't let us sell it anymore um
so i would highly suggest being here by
six o'clock so that you can get through
the line i love it so get down here by
six o'clock it's white hills arizona
just take the 11 south you can't miss
the crowd outside this line does move
fast we could have a billionaire here
tonight let me send it back to you guys
in the studio it could be chance chance
could be the billionaire
so many